let's say we discovered life Proxima
secretary B so what do you think would
happen the next day and I'm not trying
to be like you know total Cassandra
about this but I said I don't think
anything would happen and like what are
you talking about it would be
transformational I'm like I stipulate
that life exists go down to the Pacific
Ocean scoop up a glass you're gonna find
life in there and what are we doing what
are we doing to our Earth We're
destroying it let me take it a step
further how many people died
kill we mean we harm we hurt
hate
go back to what we had and I said if
that weren't proof enough life has been
discovered at least two or three times
just in my professional career we don't
give a crap so why are we thinking that
like from whence will our Salvation come
as the Bible says like it's not going to
change how we are it's not going to
magnify how I treat you or you treat me